so if you read the sentence it talked
about two things being equal if such and
such and such and such or equal what are
the two things what are the objects the
tenth and which twentieth the 10th and
20th partial sums that's what they're
talking about okay well we have language
to say the tenth partial sum we would
say the partial sum up to term ten
that's the tenth partial sum does that
make sense they're saying if that tenth
partial sum is equal to xx partial sum
if those really are equal then prove
what what is it that we're required to
prove the thirtieth one is zero hmm
prove that the thirtieth one is zero
okay pick up your pen now you have the
skeleton of what you've got to do now
you've got a basis from which you start
and you've got a destination right just
like a trig identity proof or geometry
proof or anything like that so now how
do we do this okay well this is talking
about a piece remember that I know
you're probably not up to this some
exercise yet but everything in 6a is
about arithmetic progressions so
therefore I know more than just general
stuff about the impartial song I
actually have a formula for the nth
partial sum when it comes to AP's right
remember we talked about the story of
gasps he paired up terms do you remember
what's in here we looked at this morning
so yeah so you go with the first term in
the last time right and if you want to
work out what the last term is then you
get a plus n minus 1 D there's two ways
so that's why I have 2a at the front
does that make sense
is that okay now using this formula I
can work out what s10 and s 20 ah
right and I can assume that this is true
because they told me in the question so
you help me work out what am I going to
write on the left-hand side what is s10
if that's a general partial sum I'll
give you a clue
it starts with the number 10 what am I
going to write on top of that this is
mm2 that I'm beginning with right which
in this case is 10 on 2 which is 5
that's the first bit now do I know what
the first term is does the question tell
you so this could be anything right so
I'm just gonna have to leave it as today
but I do know what n minus 1 is because
I know which partial sum I'm dealing
with so what do I write next 9 watts
excuse me King thank you not a lot so
the common difference and that's it
that's the whole formula
apparently so the question says that's
equal to the 20th partial sum so what's
that going to have on the right-hand
side there's the N on - I still don't
know what the first term is but now I
know how many common differences there
will be there there will be 18 of them
ok now this statement is true but it is
not immediately apparent how it has
anything to do with this that's okay
sometimes you're not sure where you're
going to go
what's your is seat when you look at
that line what would you like me to do
there's loads of stuff I can simplify
here write loads of stuff for example um
I can just divide these through that's
gonna give me five that's gonna give me
10 what would you like me to do now I
could expand there's nothing wrong with
expanding but before I do I noticed that
these two numbers are also connected to
each other right so before expanding our
minds won't divide both sides by 5 which
means I'd only have to worry about that
guy okay so one less thing to expand
I've got this on the left and I've got 4
a + D on the right
everything looks true I have no idea
what the relevance of this is yet but
that's okay let's see where this goes
what would you like me to do now I can
simplify but before I do this I want to
point out remember I said you this is a
proof just like a trig identity proof
just like a geometry proof now any
geometry proof I remember some of those
circle geometry proofs you get us do you
get a diagram and there'd be you know
there'd be a million angles flying
around and you're like I don't know I
don't know what's related to anything
and you could if you wanted to just find
out what every angle is equal to it but
of course that's a very inefficient way
to go about things
you know particular angles you want to
go for and so you don't just do things
randomly you go for things purposefully
now I could simplify this but as you
guys know simplify means a lot of things
right simplify sometimes it means
factorize sometimes simplify means
expand sometimes simplify means turn two
fractions into one sometimes it means
turn one fraction into two so now you
have to pause how am I going to work out
what simplify means in this context
in circle geometry and in a trig
identity proof the way you can know what
simple means in that context is where
you are going it's the destination
that's why it's so important to state
that right at the outset okay so what
would it look like for that to be true
what is sfk well it's going to look like
this isn't it it's gonna look like this
it's going to have a um it's gonna have
thirty on two at the front right we know
what that's equal to what's it gonna
have in the brackets okay
now 30 on two that's 15 the only way
that this thing could be zero is well
this thing's not going to be zero so
that means this thing needs to be zero
does that make sense
if I can establish that then I'm done so
now you know what simplify means in this
context now you know what to do with
this thing you want to find where that
is right where's that in here okay so
what do I do if I put it all on the by
this by the looks of it on the right
hand side subtract all of this over
there then you're gonna let the left
with zero on this side and two a plus
29d now the reason why I stopped before
I wrote this line is because almost no
one would say oh thank goodness it's
simplified now that doesn't look
simplified but in the context of this
question that's exactly what you need
right I can now say what would I do
I would say this I know it looks weird
to multiply everything by some number
but again in this context that is
simplified because that that's s30 do
you see that this is you see what I did
right so no like oh yeah yeah did you
learn about simplifying how simplifying
means multiplying things by random
numbers you have to know where you're
going and that decides what you're
working would be make sense